và quen tốt, quý viên đoàn trụ tịch quý bán trung lương mặt trận tổ quốc Việt Nam,
kết mạng thẳng tả để lại bài học kinh nghiệm cuối giá về phát viên sức mạnh đoàn kết toàn xanh tộc.
Phát viên sức mạnh của quân trung nhận dân, làm nên thành công bị đại.
Chắc khi điều khiến khi đảng ta vừa mới đời được mấy lắm nả.
Nhưng mặc quý thình, đi đường lối đúng tán của ta,
vóa ký sự lý xanh bà của hình yên người đảng viên khăn bộ đảng viên.
Và được trái hông tức cả tập hợp trong mặt trận về đời bây,
phùi đậu xức mạnh mộ hình rồi về đăng không phinh bệ trái thức dân tộc tôn ráo,
với tình thành đều đứt vộn lên để trình tăng kẻ thủ.
Nên quý sấu thằng tắm, lạnh tồng phải nghĩ ở được phát bố,
lạnh tụ hồ chí mình đã kêu quợi đông bào cả nước đứng dài,
đem xức tà mà dài không trở thành.
Đáp lại lời chưa hỏi đó, đúng bào cả nước đã đông và tứng dài
tính hành tồng phải giã, dành chính quyền ở phát cây địa phần.
Ngay mươi chính thẳng tám nămu ngìn chính trọng của người làm từ các cộp
quần chúng nhân dân rất cao cơ đỏ só phàn và biểu ngữ
tính về nhà hát lớn và chung tâm thành phố,
tham sạch hình giã, tạo khi thế cách mặt mạnh mẽ,
chếm các cơ quan tụng dở trọng yêu của địa.
Cả nước theo gương hả nội đã nhất thế đứng lên khởi giã thành công,
dành được đốc lập cho xin tạo.
Chủ tịch hồ chính mình từ nối,
đoàn kết là lực lượng bố định.
Tháng lợi của tổng phy nghĩa tháng tám nămu ngìn chính trọng của người làm
đã khảm định phá trò và sức mạnh của quần chúng nhân dân.
Sao tám năm, ý nghĩa vào hó kinh nghiệm của các bạn tháng tám
và tố cùng thiết thực.
Đó là để đất lất ngày cảm ứng lên, tàng,
phải giữa và nhân dân viên nhân dân và chiến đấu và phục quốc.
Lua nguần gánh bó mật thiết với nhân dân
và tuy cao đổ sức mạnh của nhân dân.